pour cette enquête
notre équipe a pris le bois nous avons
formé un groupe de chasseurs en quête
d'un territoire dans la forêt publique
nous faisons comme des dizaines de
milliers de chasseurs qui chaque année
au québec veulent chasser le rien sur
les terres publiques
la loi garantit à tous le droit d'y
chasser
c'est ce droite nous voulons tout
simplement exercer mais nous allonger de
comprendre que nous ne sommes pas les 10
venu certains sont prêts à jouer dur
pour gagner et conserver un territoire
de chasse
chaque année au québec d'écartement sont
des mots ni d'autres sont brûlés des
claques sur la gueule je donne et les
menaces qu
[Musique]
c'est une guerre qui se déroule dans
toutes les régions forestières notre
équipe s'est rendue en gaspésie une
région où les tensions sont
particulièrement vives
[Musique]
nous commençons notre prospection par la
seigneurie du lac matapédia un
territoire très giboyeux mais réputés
hospitaliers envers les nouveaux
chasseurs
[Musique]
c'est dans ce secteur que nous avons
choisi d'installer notre campement en ce
début septembre la chasse n'a pas encore
commencé sur les terres publiques
en principe c'est un bon moment pour
s'établir
nous nous sommes installés en bordure
d'un chemin forestier en pleine forêt
publique
c'est ce qu'on appelle deux territoires
libres
[Musique]
une population des caméras de
surveillance
et comme le font beaucoup de chasseurs
nous affichons ouvertement notre
intention de revenir chassé par ici dans
quelques semaines il n'y a aucun autre
campement en vue nous laissons tout de
même un numéro de téléphone
[Musique]
nous poursuivons notre exploration des
chemins du secteur presque partout les
revendications territoriales sont
claires plus de l'an randall c avant un
carnet ont possédé par eddy pourriez
paradis paradis vol un bon bout du monde
du coin boisement de monde
du coup ce résidant de la région que
nous avons croisé par hasard nous laisse
avec un conseil d'ami
un homme averti en vaut deux
[Musique]
la gaspésie est un authentique paradis
de l'orignal la coupe forestière
intensive des dernières décennies à
l'essai de vastes territoires en
régénération
la nourriture y est abondante et la
population d'orignaux a explosé des
chasseurs de partout au québec veulent
tenter leur chance dans cet eldorado
la quasi-totalité de la forêt publique
il est déjà occupé il est nouveau venu
ne sont pas toujours bien accepté
[Musique]
au bout de quelques jours
notre campement du lac matapédia a été
repéré celui qui nous appellent se nomme
pierre ou chouinard
on le voit sur ces images au moment où
ils découvrent notre temps ils menacent
de tout raser d'étape public l'on peut
quand même se trouver un coin tous
chassés si les mots ne suffisent pas
monsieur chouinard laisse entendre que
d'autres moyens de pression pourraient
s'exercer
30 et sur vos propres créations et vous
serez pas lancé
mais au moment même où caire où
chouinard nous fait ces menaces au
téléphone
d'autres individus d'un autre groupe que
le sien sont déjà sur place nous caméra
capte la scène c'est du vol tout d'abord
notre bidon d'essence et notre bâche
avant tout simplement de tout démolir
nous reviendrons avant longtemps pour
tenter de rencontrer ceux qui nous ont
réservé cet accueil fait septembre nous
nous trouvons dans un autre secteur de
la région alors que débute la saison
consacrée à l'arc et à l'arbalète la
chasse à la carabine viendra plus tard
nous sommes dans la zec cazaux près de
causapscal nous n'allons pas tarder à
apprendre quels secteurs où nous
pénétrons est subdivisé en fief sur
lesquels différents groupes font la loi
nous entrons dans une zone appelée
girardville tenus par le groupe de
typologie ramené de la palette
l'argumentation a tout de suite débuté
par la question de nos origines
montréal contre la gaspésie n'allons pas
tarder à découvrir que c'est un des
ressorts puissant de la dynamique locale
avec vous convient pas vous
non mais vous venez passer pendant ce
temps il y en a pas de place donc il n'y
a guère de place en tout cas pour la
discussion
je n'ai pas regardé ce que j'appelle un
chat peut se retourner parce que oui
voir les gens sont égaux pour voir venir
ici
[Musique]
les chasseurs d'orignaux déploie une
énergie considérable pour s'enfoncer
dans le bois
ils poursuivent tous le même rêve celui
d'un territoire immense giboyeux et si
possible libre de tout chasseur le
nirvana c'est l'affût dans le silence et
l'intimité de la forêt l'orignal est de
nature méfiante et farouche et sa chasse
exige une approche furtive plus
compatible avec la présence d'autres
chasseurs dans les environs de chasseurs
d'orignal recherche donc le territoire
le plus exclusif possible
mais dans la gaspésie d'aujourd'hui
cette quête devient presque impossible
ces montagnes les forêts étaient
pratiquement vierge dans les années 70
cette carte représente un secteur
typique de la région
les exploitants forestiers y ont créé un
véritable spaghetti de chemins d'accès
le mythe de la grande forêt vierge
gaspésienne un mort on peut désormais
pénétrer partout il y à des chasseurs
partout c'est cette situation qui
entraîne une dégradation majeure des
relations entre les chasseurs
ça devient une chasse une chasse à
l'homme
jacques castonguay un résidant de laval
s'est offert une semaine de chasse avec
ses amis sur la zec cazaux près de
causapscal une zec ou zones
d'exploitation contrôlée est un
territoire géré par une association de
chasseurs et de pêcheurs
un peu comme une coopérative on paie
pour venir y chasser mais la forêt
publique est un principe d'accès c'est
d'être tous ceux qui ont payé
en principe je laval puis je pourrais
très bien venu ici je lis des compris qu
à l'apport que on se dit fathi assez
assez clairement
mais comprenez vous quand même que c'est
des gens de la région puis que vous
venez de l'extérieur sur des terres que
fréquent 20 de génération en génération
écoute on était quand même au québec je
crois que je fais quoi
puis que je crois que j'ai 3 surtout que
je paye un droit je paye un doigt je me
fais dire qu'ils sont un territoire
libre qui dont non libres quand on se
fait aussi de partout
si beaucoup de chasseurs recule devant
l'opposition jacques castonguay et son
gros eux ont décidé de chasser quand
même ça profite à la peur à personne
qu'on vient de chasser ici parce que les
gaspésiens c'est tout la même chose
c'est leur territoire c'est leur
montagne qu'on à laval je vous pose
c'est quoi l'intérêt de darva à l'offre
il y en a eu beaucoup d incident moi
tout les jours à toutes les jours à
matin c'était pareil
les gommes attendait un organe plus loin
dans le but chez capa personnes qui
chasse les gauches aspo lyon aucune
arbalète à rien il me tarde pause l'oeil
était tout en gagnant matin qui
m'attendait mais encore une fois ils
m'ont frappé ma chasse ils me suivent à
la trace et je parle je suis garni
[Musique]
c'est mon cher monsieur endroit on joue
au con nature a pas besoin de conflits
on était dans un endroit qui s'appelle
le secteur à monsieur tomassi s'appelle
de la fameux monsieur
la voix je la vois ce n'est ni la
première ni la dernière fois que ce nom
surgit dans notre enquête
gilles lavoie est un policier à la
retraite de la sûreté du québec
il a déjà siégé au conseil
d'administration de la zec il est
surtout connu comme le roi de cette
montagne qui surplombe le lac cazaux les
groupes qui chassent dans les secteurs
adjacents sont alliés avec lui et tous
entendre pour défendre contre des intrus
ce vaste territoire de plusieurs
dizaines de kilomètres carrés gilles
lavoie lui même la chasse pas l'orignal
pendant la saison de l'arc
ce qui ne l'empêchent pas de garder
farouchement son territoire et de faire
le guet pendant cette période
monsieur lavoie et reçues concernant son
territoire le lendemain à 5 ans le matin
il était dans sa cache talent de ce qu
elle est exposée de chasser la perdrix
je dirais que c'est sa cage on a attendu
que joe ogilvie c'est le comble vu qu'on
a continué le d'al-bicher g20 au regard
d'un groupe de damon thomas regarde le
voyage en italie de penser devant
monsieur lavoie nous a laissés procès le
vu leur génial aussi le but lorient n'a
fait que je me suis placé sa point de
voir mon film j'ai commencé colis sans
amener on le voyait bien en bouche et en
europe
le géant montre en or la loi en lançant
vient près partout et monsieur lavoie
qui a vu leur règne a descendu de sa
cache non embarquées sont quatre ou et à
votre douce qu'on est à 2 300 pinzon il
ya débarqué il ya lancé des roches
l'orignal nous fait remarquer notre
chasse
ce ne fut pas leur seul altercation avec
gilles lavoie au cours de ce même voyage
le récit de cet autre chasseur du groupe
premier matin que la chasse aux voix et
le samedi matin
jeumont à s'installer d'un budget on
était là à 5 1 la chasse rompre avant 6
fait qu'il attend des spots et puis dès
la vue qui va hanter pendant le faisait
froid j'étais mme raîche au fil d'une
cache que j'y venais d'arriver à
cabannes lui est arrivé en fou dans le
chemin qu'a vu le sun en cabane à
débarquer son 4 ou et amorcer son fusil
distant 20h58 le fusil comme ça des
réserves ballet commence à me donner de
l'amour tandis que super meat de cendres
qui saperait et lui donne pas les
cotisations sur 10 mirador me tall et je
vois c'est un bar voyons ça se fait pas
de sortie sont physiquement je la vois s
qui a pointé son nez pointé son arme il
a sorti son fusil puis en marche en
direction de mon ami mais il n'ya pas
pointer son arme directement sur lui
mais tu peux pas sortir un homme
affirmant c'est intimidant mont chaiten
héroïque cheikh est après le chasseur
s'est plaint à la sûreté du québec un
membre de son groupe filmait la scène
des agentes n'ont pas enregistré de
plainte officielle
hyundai qui vous avez l'impression vous
que
les agents de la cuy qui sont venus vous
trouvez pour enregistrer votre
déposition et ont changé d'attitude
succès deux mois plus tard et après
avoir été informé de la diffusion
prochaine de notre reportage
la sûreté du québec a décidé de
transmettre la plainte à un procureur
aucune accusation n'a encore été portée
deux semaines se sont écoulées nous
sommes revenus sur la zac cazaux pour
l'ouverture de la chasse à la carabine
il fait encore nuit lorsque nous
arrivons sur le territoire de l'ancien
policier gilles lavoie
un véhicule a été placé à l'entrée du
secteur
il s'agit d'un leurre il a été placé là
pour faire croire que des chasseurs sont
déjà sur place mais ses vitres sont
embués
et il est évident qu'il n'a pas roulé
depuis longtemps
tandis que nous préparons nos armes
une voiture ce point gilles lavoie sort
de sa voiture un coût de 20 et n'a pas
tu as à perdre avec les politesses
[Applaudissements]
certes on est dans notre onze autres le
lecteur il s est montré
ok nous avons bien joué au delà tomber
dans les troubles
c'est trop gros pour arriver de nulle
part le savez vous ce que vous en avez
marre et on est prêt et rsa ce fait les
choeurs et par personne ne respecte pas
les héroïnes il est clair qu'une somme a
priori d importants et des transferts
cpt arrive de nulle part
ces saletés section pas et creusent
partout on travaille on estime à l'eau
depuis les années 50 que je suis avec
mon rire et au pays qu'il y ait très peu
de débris de cette tocade hauts de
verbier mis encore gilles lavoie n'ira
pas jusqu'à tenter de nous empêcher de
passer
de son propre aveu les particulièrement
prudents depuis ces altercations avec le
groupe de laval et la visite qu'il a
reçus de la sûreté du québec gilles
lavoie n'en est pas à son premier
accrochage
je suis arrivé dans un territoire qui
était gardée par des rites et j'ai été
arrêtée la part
quelqu'un par un dénommé gilles de la
voix qui m'a bien expliqué que je
pourrais pas chasser l'eau parce que
c'était son territoire et les trottoirs
de leur amie kat à l'appel de l'orignal
l'ancien chroniqueur de chasse et pêche
andré croteau connu des auditeurs de
radio canada a eu le malheur il y a
trois ans de s'aventurer sur la montagne
jean lavoie
je vais vous dire tout de suite qui en a
eu un accrochage assez sérieux sur le
coup mais
je n'étais pas en nombre pour partir une
guerre donc je veux retourner sur mes
pas ce n'était que le premier d'une
série d'incidents qui allait marquer son
voyage et celui de ses amis mon
compagnon louis langelier lui était allé
s'installer à quelque part ailleurs et
tout à coup il est arrivé des démos des
des petits véhicules de vtt et des gens
qui se remet à tirer du fusil au tour
pour apeurer gibier carrément portion de
cette info déranger sa chasse était très
évident je suis essayée
à trois reprises et parfois reprises
j'ai été apostrophé engueuler
par gilles lavoie ensuite la voix et
d'autres personnes aussi te font
comprendre lorsque tu as lu dans un
territoire comme ça qu avec un beau
camion que des bonbons tenu comme tu
l'as dit lui même ça coûte passablement
d'argent
à remplacer nous sommes allés trouver
gilles lavoie à sa cache pour lui
demander une entrevue il a refusé
mais au cours de notre conversation il
s'est défendu d' empêcher les gens de
chasser père obstacle c'est empêcher
quelqu'un de passer et rien dans la loi
qui dit t'as pas le droit d'envoyer chez
quelqu'un nous n'obtiendrons guère plus
si ce n'est de nombreux commentaires sur
ce qu'il appelle des morons de montréal
ou de la vad
sur les réseaux sociaux je la vois
cultive cette animosité entre les
gaspésie et les gens de la ville ceux
qui comme il le répète souvent viennent
de nulle part des effrontées qui par ce
qui vient de la ville disent que nous
gaspésien sommes des demeurés
nous rapportons au président par intérim
de la zec cazaux claude tremblay les
nombreux témoignages que nous avons
cumulé sur les faits et gestes attribué
à g de la voix le roi de la montagne la
fopac faut pas qu'ils se plantent pour
les dominants on va analyser les faits
chose certaine c'est officiel que si une
personne devient trop devient trop trop
agressif puis y est cela le monde que
tout c'est officiel que après un
printemps médiane assemblée générale on
va passer nous et puis tout pied de
monsieur peut-être mais on peut dire un
monsieur ou hirsch assayas à peu aux
points juste pour mieux la voir je parle
pour tout le monde en général
le symbole par excellence de
l'appropriation des territoires de
chasse
ce sont les cachent ou post d'affût
lorsqu'elles sont en hauteur on parle de
miradors des chevaux ou deux tours dans
le langage local
ce sont des watch les cachets revient
sur à chasser mais elles servent aussi à
délimiter son territoire en signifiant
aux nouveaux venus que le coin est pris
et qu'il vaut mieux aller voir ailleurs
comme elles servent à marquer un
territoire des caches sont aussi très
souvent les premières cibles de la
guerre c'était ma cage que j'arrivais
cet homo septembre hugo lemay a trahi le
chemin d'un oui c'est écrit mécanique
l'eau à lyon défaite mais j'avoue là je
sais quoi il veut prendre territoire
mais oui
la forêt publique est criblé de cash
permanente c'est aussi le cas sur des
zecs et plusieurs y voient une forme de
privatisation du territoire masculin
mais des cachets en a partout c'est
toulouse tout sur une cache je peux pas
y aller mais ça veut dire qu'il n'a pas
de territoire parce que si je sais des
caches si si tu regardes tous partout il
y en a ça veut dire qu'on peut pas
chasser les zecs ont été créés dans la
vague de contestations populaires des
années 70 alors que des chasseurs et des
pêcheurs réclamaient l'abolition des
privilèges exclusifs détenues par les
membres des clubs privés un minimum de
dignité d'être capable de voyager dans à
peine arrivée au pouvoir le gouvernement
de rené lévesque en fait une de ses
toutes premières réformes en 1977 il
annonce la fin des clubs privés ce que
nous retirons l'exclusivité des droits
de chasse et pêche et leur remplacement
par des zones d'exploitation contrôlée
des territoires ouverts à tous qui
seront autogérée par les chasseurs et
les pêcheurs
[Musique]
mais en réalité les ex n'ont pas de
pouvoir même pas celui de gérer
l'épineux problème des caches d'un
accord on n'a pas le droit la région
blouin est administrateur de la zac cap
chat en gaspésie
parce que pour réglementer quelque chose
il faudrait que la carte soit reconnu et
le ministère reconnaît pas les cassures
l'heure actuelle alors si les cachais
pas légal il peut pas donner le droit
des règlements t elle vendre 1,2 et
qu'on n'a pas le droit de faire une
cache permanente dans la fois c'est sûr
ça veut dire la loi sur les terres du
domaine de l'état semble clair nul ne
peut diriger ou maintenir un bâtiment
une installation ou un ouvrage sur une
terre sans une autorisation du ministre
en pratique cependant les cages sont
toujours été tolérée
c'est loin d'être le cas partout dans
les provinces limitrophes du québec par
exemple au nouveau brunswick ou en
ontario les chasseurs n'ont le droit de
construire que des miradors provisoire
et sont tenus de les enlever
à la fin de la chasse
en 2009 réjean blouin siéger sur le
comité d'experts qui s'est penché sur
l'appropriation du territoire par les
chasseurs en gaspésie parmi les
recommandations on pouvait lire celle ci
à moyen terme éliminer totalement la
présence de cash permanente sur le
territoire une proposition qui a été
reçue comme une douche froide par les
associations de chasseurs de la région
et qui n'a eu aucune suite
la première réforme que le plus
important c'est d'interdir toute
construction solide sur place tout un
truc tout con struction permanent sur
place sans quelqu'un
keith savage le droit d'installer une
tour et souvent qui coûte plusieurs
centaines de dollars
après ça se croient ou d'y avoir un
territoire où un droit sur ce territoire
donc élimination manu militari immédiat
de toutes les installations solaires sur
la zec du bas saint laurent près de
rimouski
on y est allé d'une réforme moins
radicale mais qui est souvent citée en
exemple et jean territoire personnel il
y avait des limites d'accès à 20
demandes par exemple il ya déjà
construits en cash et se met à les louer
et pour pouvoir les personnels à
intimider les visiteurs au terme d'une
assemblée générale houleuse tenue en
1996 on a limité les caches à une seule
par chasseur celle ci est enregistrée à
partir d'un point de localisation gps et
ça finit là plusieurs membres ont quitté
la zec à la suite de cette réforme
mais la paix sociale en attirer d'autres
il pensait hauteur de 89 cents mans puis
on et 2200 âmes à peu près puis on vous
dit qu'il ya encore un peu la fédération
des aigles du québec considère que cette
approche est le modèle à suivre
mais pratiquement aucune zec n'appuie
l'implanter partout on s'y est essayé
comme la zec cazaux les membres s'y sont
opposés en assemblée générale
chantale gagné est directrice générale
de la zac cazaux elle est bien
consciente que sadek est confronté au
détournement du mandat et a dissous le
gouvernement d'évêques au fil des
guerres d'appropriation du territoire
elle commence à ressembler à un club
privé
arina sentiments comme de droite ça fait
tellement longtemps que chez nous c'est
moi qui ai pris acte en tant directeur
leur disais souvent rappelé en novembre
que les territoires est ouvert tout le
monde pour qu'un seul groupe de
chasseurs pas seulement qu'aux gens de
la région où si tout va avec tout le
monde ce n'est pas chantal bernier ça
n'est pas de conseil d'administration ce
n'est pas l'assemblée générale qui l'a
décidé c'est le gouvernement lorsqu'une
crise est rentré chez lui à laval après
sa chasse à l'arbalète une surprise
désagréable attendait jacques castonguay
la sûreté du québec lui a confisqué ses
armes à feu un chasseur de la zac cazaux
jerry york l'a accusé d'avoir proféré
des menaces de mort à son endroit
jerry or est un voisin territoire de
gilles lavoie et un de ses alliés dans
l'affrontement avec les chasseurs de
laval c'est sur le territoire que hortes
occupe avec sa famille que jacques
castonguay avait établi son campement ce
qui avait donné lieu à une conversation
téléphonique venimeuse entre les deux
hommes ainsi comme jauge caniche ou
hadopi loi c'est une main timide et ou
j'aime pas intimider toute personne qui
s'appuie sur les kilts c'est à ce moment
selon jerry york que jacques castonguay
leur est menacée
nous arrivons à notre tour sur le
territoire ou chasse jerry york son
camion bloque l'accès au territoire et
nous lui demandons le passage de la
place mais le problème nous montre et on
essaie de se respecter
oui à ces soirées se reprenait avec ceux
de montréal monsieur woerth a enlevé son
véhicule
quelques heures plus tard lorsque nous
lui expliquant que nous sommes
journalistes
il refuse de donner une entrevue
en confisquant césar la sûreté du québec
un interdit à jacques castonguay de
s'approcher de la zone de chasse de
jerry york
qu'à cela ne tienne il est quand même
revenu sur la zec cazaux il n'a pas
d'armes à feu il n'a qu'a traversée le
chemin pour chasser du côté de gilles
lavoie et à la tombée du jour
le comble ses produits son ami stif a
tué un orignal projet l'eau pure gars
parfait
tout est bon je fais l'objet histoire se
finit bien
elle est un petit peu mais disons que
moi qu'est la première fois qu'on est
venu à l'arbalète les ânes fatma acquis
1 dans le bûcher fait que longueur
samedi si l'intention n'était pas de le
provoquer donc du tout du tout du tout
parce que si jaro du le provoquer c'est
dans son bûcher shalit personnel à lui
puis si c'est pas son but où tout c'est
peut-être dans sa taille son secteur
c'est postiches ask
pour cet automne cet épisode de la
guerre des bois semble terminée mais
est-ce bien terminé jacques castonguay
doit attendre un jugement de la cour
pour savoir s'il pourra ou non
récupérer ces armes à feu sans quoi il
promet un retour en force des brochets
lé prochain raconte un policier
c'est ce réseau fin d'année prochaine
[Musique]
ce sont les jours de la grande
effervescence donné vie essais d'hiver
nous sommes revenues vers la seigneurie
du lac matapédia
nous ouvrons les ruines de notre
campement
nous avions monté notre tente sur une
portion de chemin qui traverse le
territoire occupé par le clan des
chouinard du village de sayabec
le doyen du groupe c'est bertrand
chouinard dit yves chouinard
il chasse avec ses fils et quelques amis
selon plusieurs sources les chouinard
s'en prennent même à ceux qui
s'approchent de leur secteur en
circulant sur ce chemin public
nous décidons d'aller voir à qui nous
avons affaire nous l'ignorons encore
mais l'avant veille un incident
dramatique a eu lieu ici même chaque
grain ya deux ans via lé là j'ai arrêté
la voiture marque grâce et sa compagne
qu'il aime de beauport se trouvait sans
savoir sur le territoire de la famille
chouinard le voc se mijote un peu de
côté qui était juste bien placé pour
tirer le chef et qui est pas tombé
dessus un vacarme dans le dos il ya des
colis a fait à peu près je vous dirai
peut-être 30 pieds gros match loïs
lamentait gt1 en espadrilles je me suis
dit je vais quatre voitures sont
arrivées d'un coup ces cinq personnes ne
se regarde partout connaissait pas les
personnes peut-être des gens qui
voulaient m'aider
marc roche n'allait pas tarder à revenir
sur cette première impression là j'avais
mis brad j'ai continué à avancer ce joli
but chaque oeil là-dessus facture
riquet la carabine jure donne un
deuxième cours l'oi at on attaque les
bleus sont partis en courant
la dernière deux sont arrivés à vous
irez 5 6 pieds d'orignal il y en a
quelques uns qui saqqara des piliers
tirer leur mire d'un bail
[Musique]
lolo et yadi et ya mille coups mortels
et oui c'est en normes ias aux cloches
qui était déjà en train de mourir non
non non non le coup mortel senzo t il
son cndd aux lions et des carabiniers
pour féliciter le gpo attendu plus
lointain parce que j'étais comme de trop
à leur pari même si nous sommes en droit
de chasse syrie si nous avançons sans
mains de porter de carabine sur le
chemin revendiquées par l'islam
nous ne tardons pas sans rencontrer
bertrand chouinard j'avais attrapé ma
vie j'étais puis d'un ego qui travaille
tout le temps qui fait des salières et
poignant go qui conclut on invite des
puits pour mettre le cheval garde
franchement là
chez ses parents
monsieur chouinard est visiblement de
mauvaise humeur mais il est seul son
attitude va changer dès qu'il entend
venir des autres membres de son groupe
c'est quoi c'est les autres le testing
et sur bab amro gaspo anatolie bien que
le tabac picchu qu'un portable et
l'appareil pour des photos osées
question monsieur délégation écoute ici
vous n'avez pas de trop à dépenser ce
que vous
voir sonic photo on aperçoit notre
lettre q des premiers choix mais vous
avez fait arié d'arriver ici c'est à
dire pas le seul territoire de près de
100 kg car pas la face en quoi ces coûts
[Applaudissements]
les juges japonais oui votre c'est lui
c'est lui qui parlait si c'est lui santé
qui parler marc roche nous a confirmé
l'identité de ceux qui l'accusent
d'avoir pris son origine
donc ça c'est bertrand chouinard ça
c'est monsieur qui a tiré
on comprend bien que marc rost seul ait
pas eu envie de débattre davantage gens
vous restez respectez pas parfait pour
marc cross et orignal restera malgré
tout son premier jeu aucune faute aux
premiers engagés du jeu les vues je les
utilise les voeux mourir mais s'arrêter
là les querelles entre chasseurs sont
loin d'être une priorité pour les agents
de la faune mais il y a bien un article
du règlement qui protège le droit de
chasser mais des agents sont là d'abord
pour protéger le gibier pas les
chasseurs moi c'est une réalité
c'est quand même notre travail il va
taxer beaucoup sur le biologique ou le
très dommageable pour la faune donc des
conflits entre usagers
on va les traiter mais notre priorité
reste ou en vertu des activités les plus
dommageables pour la peau les agents de
la faune ne sont par ailleurs qu'une
poignée pour couvrir des territoires
immenses
les effectifs du poste de causapscal ne
sont que le tiers de ce qu'ils étaient
il ya vingt ans alors que nombre de
chasseurs a plus que doublé
les patrouilles du territoire ont été
pratiquement aboli
la patrouille conventionnelle est
restreinte puisque c'est une philosophie
qui vient d
des réalités budgétaires pour ce mât
gouvernement et rendu au bout de la
sones fait que on envoie pour ben
garde-chasse encore moins à mener
jusqu'à date
j'en ai même pas vu un homme ça fait que
les gens prennent pour acquis bon mais
pas de garde à chasser au paintball sur
notre route nous avons rencontré martin
laverdière
il est policier de profession chasseurs
d'orignal par passion ils observent
depuis longtemps d'un oeil critique les
ravages de la guerre des bois du moment
qu'ils aient les quatre roues du
véhicule qui l'acheminera asphalte est
piqueté genton sur le chemin de gravier
nord on dirait que toute forme de loi
n'existe plus
tant que le gouvernement avait décidé de
dire je mets mes culottes l'eau on vote
des lois qui sont tellement sévères quel
moment donné on va mettre fin un saut en
forêt alors il n'y a pas de volonté
politique
mougins tout court ça fait 29 ans que
chasse à l'orignal sur le territoire us
in j'ai chassé avant soit dans le bourg
de montmagny puis c'est ça tout voté la
même problématique c'est que les gens
sont en forêt ils font ce qu'ils veulent
puis à l'issue de ce que ce qu'ils ont
fait c'est que son pop unis avant qu'ils
aient quelque chose qui arrive justement
avant qu'il ya un conflit petit et 2 go
qui se battent point sarioglu qui arrive
de quoi de grave tout cas les dacquois
remonter parce que c'est sûr savoir mais
c'est certain que ça va rebaisser péridy
d'art en son sens par le pont c'est ça
va finir à m'emmener que quelqu'un qui
va soigner puis s'asseoir provost ce qui
va arriver
ceux qui se livrent à l'intimidation qui
ne sont qu'une minorité
photo tort considérable à l'image de la
chasse en général et en particulier à
celles de la gaspésie je juge aucun
intérêt de retourner dans cette région
loge pense que les gens de l'extérieur
de son pot bienvenue en gaspésie c'est
sûr que moi n'ont jamais géré tourner en
gaspésie pour la chasse parce que j'ai
eu comme condiment le sont en fin de
compte c'est l'économie régionale qui en
souffrent une de nos ressources pour
être serré largeur le cas demain est
vraiment les ressources naturelles dont
la chasse et la pêche
mais si on contingent tous pendus
prépare n'y a pas de place il n'est plus
de retombées économiques là parce que
c'est pas le monsieur de la place qui
fait les puis l'autre tombé comem et en
seulement deux semaines par année la
chasse injecte 12 millions et demi de
dollars dans l'économie gaspésienne
le potentiel est sans doute beaucoup
plus grand mais l'anarchie actuelle en
forêt publique ne favorise pas sa mise
en valeur
il aurait un potentiel d'exploitation si
on organisait le territoire sur le seul
modèle des réserves
on note simplement aujourd'hui des
chemins d'accès partout on n'a qu'à
diviser le territoire en unités et les
offrir au tirage au sort et chacun
pourrait aller à tour de rôle on
pourrait chasser de septembre à décembre
si on voulait y aurait pas d'objection
sur le plan de la faune pour réduire la
pression
[Musique]
sur place
la vie la mort le sang et les armes la
chasse à l'orignal est un théâtre
d'émotions fortes
c'est une activité souvent rude et
exigeante
les hommes se laisse pousser la barbe le
vernis de la civilisation cac on veut
chasser on veut récolter puis souvent on
veut trop fait sur thève l'autre fait
donc on fait tout pour ça et puis c'est
un sport mais c'est pas tous les gens
qui ont même niveau esprit sportif
la forêt publique appartient à tous la
loi de la jungle qui prévaut en ce
moment n'est pas forcément immuable
c'est un débat qui au québec n'a pas
encore eu lieu